Speaker 1: If you want people to vote for you,
you might not want to say that their state is
a disgrace. A complete and total softball Trump
interview went horribly wrong, where Trump called
Nevada disgraceful when he was asked about,
Hey, you lost twice, What's your plan to win
in 2024? This is so endlessly fascinating. Trump
was interviewed by the this is called the Nevada
Globe. Okay. The Nevada Globe. The Globe interview
of President Donald Trump. I encourage you to look
at all of this. The picture of Trump sitting there
on a podcast interview while they were with him is
really, really wild stuff. It's like, this is
a transcript. Okay, this is a text interview.
There's a fascinating section I want to focus in
on the interviewer say to Trump, So let's talk.
Nevada Governor Lombardo lost Clark County by
six points. He lost Washoe County by two points,
yet he still won the governorship. Additionally,
he's recently signed legislation that awards
$25 million to the Culinary Union. The Nevada
Republican Party believes that that money is going
to be used for ballot harvesting. Proponents
claim it's going to be used for a capital
improvement project that hasn't been identified.
A Republican presidential candidate hasn't won
Nevada since 2004. You lost Nevada twice. How do
you win Nevada? Look at Trump's answer. I think
I won the last time. I think I won both times
by a lot. This is a state that is disgraceful.
Listen, you lost twice here. How are you going
to turn it around? How are you going to win?
This state is an absolute disgrace. Vote for this
man right away. I mean, just not even passing the
sniff test for what is going to help him. And
Trump goes on to say, you know, we sued on the
basis of they robbed the vote at a level we had a
lawsuit that was so good and the judge didn't want
to see it. He didn't even want to see it. We had a
lawsuit that was, in my opinion, conclusive. But,
you know, we have guys like Laxalt. Laxalt was a
very weak candidate. He was pathetic. You know,
I help Laxalt do the best he could. I guess
his grandfather was strong, his father was
good. But I guess the chain got weaker and weaker.
Remember, the question was, how are you going to
win Nevada after losing it twice? Trump's talking
about nonsense. But Adam Laxalt is a stiff and
he didn't do the job. He was a lawyer. He was
working for a lot of different people on trying
to do the vote thing, but he wasn't the right
guy. When you see Trump's words as a transcript,
they are ten times nuttier and more meaningless.
Trump going on. We have great people working now.
We have great lawyers working. They used COVID
to cheat the last time they used COVID to cheat.
But we think we have a great team in place to
stop it. We are then asked to wrap the interview
by. Okay. And then they go on to talk, talk to
Trump a little bit more. This it's beyond parody,
really. It's B when he's asked about the fact
that he lost and how will you win? He insists
I actually won. I actually love the transcript
of the Trump interview. I think it's a great
thing because it really makes it for people who
read, write, who know how to read. It makes the
statements even more meaningless where he just
sort of trails off and skips around from one topic
to another. So Trump's strategy to win Nevada is
going to be it is calling the state a disgrace,
insisting he actually won, even though he lost.
And I guess saying that they're going to fix it
by something related to ballot harvesting.
Not a winning strategy in Nevada. My bets on
Joe Biden in Nevada if if I'm totally honest
with you. But we we will have to wait and see